compared to what compared to not having
equality compared to 100 years ago yes
compared to 50 years ago yes compared to
most places in the world throughout
history yes compared to a hypothetical
ideal no
to what you have fragments but then
isn't an ideology no it's not an
ideology and it isn't a strong
collection of ideas in a sense always an
ideal no it's not it's not and it's a
mistake to think that way because all
that means is that the way that you
construe the world is there's a
Battleground between different
ideologies yes shut up it's like God I'm
so tired of the wine Jordan come on the
show come on what up guys welcome to the
just curlythings YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series before I
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
the way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos like the video on your
way in uh let's get started so today I
am going to be reacting to Jordan P
Jordan Peterson talking about how hard
women have it the big bad patriarchy
that's just against us because my life
as a woman is so hard pull the footage
King all right so this lady let's see
but she's got a pants suit on she's got
short hair dyed red she could be a
feminine one it's actually crazy how
much the world changed after birth
control because you could have these
feminist ideologies but you couldn't do
about it you're gonna get pregnant
you know what I mean so it's like but
now it's it's so crazy how when women
get the power to we act so selfishly
it's so crazy like you know and people
get on me for hating women but it's like
I look at what happens when we get power
and I'm like when we have leverage we
just are not the best people in general
um there's exceptions there's great
women out there but you know it's like
when we get power yeah we really act
very selfishly we we you know we go into
the workforce and then sue people for
harassment we meet two men we you know
created a child support system that
basically you know take half and leave
so you know women can't really get do
like deal with leverage too well I think
Andrew Tate made a very good point about
feminism on these I this sort of
ideology any idea energy that can't be
defended by the people that hold them
it's kind of useless and it has a a a a
shelf life because the reality is
eventually all this craziness is going
to get to the breaking point and then
men are going to be like you know what
we need to take this back and the
reality is at the end of the day we may
keep shouting about our power power this
power that power is never given it has
to be taken so until we may figure out a
way to take power because even amongst
men no man is going to go to the next
one and say can you give me power nah
you're going to have to figure out a way
to take it for yourself did you know
there was some of the roots of feminism
is from like this cult or this like
religion in India that that like
basically took man and sacrificed them
to the Gods like for women so like when
they say I'm a goddess I'm an emperor
it's like from that religion it's like
in the horoscope yeah it's like
from that religion yeah that's that's
demonic yeah I know you have to go you I
seriously guys
I'm the interview I did with Rachel
Wilson it was so interesting like I
learned so much about the history of
feminism but I think I think we're gonna
close it there
um yeah just another feminist being oh
so logical and being so thankful to men
and for all the rights and privileges
that they've given us I'm being very
kind to Jordan
um and really just standing up for my
rights as a woman because I'm also
oppressed and my life is so hard uh let
me know what you guys think in the
comments you know maybe I'm crazy I
don't know
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time